Given, 12x-3(5x+1)=-3x-3,
what will happen if I
ask you to solve for x?
This one's actually even
trickier than it looks, so
here are all the steps to solve it.
I first rewrote the equation
as 12x+(-3)(5x+1)=-3x- 3.
To make the negative sign
easier to distribute,
I distributed the -3 to the terms
inside the parentheses.
I simplified a bit, and
rewrote the equation as 12x-15x-3=-3x-3.
I combine like terms, and things are
starting to look a little funny here.
-3x-3=-3x-3.
Okay, well let's keep going.
I added 3 to both sides and
got -3x+0=-3x+0.
All right, stranger still.
And then, I'm left with -3x=-3x,
then I divided by -3 on both sides and
I just get x=x.
So what does that mean?
In algebra, we call this type of
an equation, an identity equation,
x equals itself, that's its identity, so
that means I could put an any value for
x, and it won't change
what this equation means.
Here, I could have divided
by x instead of -3 and
I would have gotten -3=-3, again,
that's an identity, -3 is -3.
The important thing to remember here
is that the solution is stated,
all real numbers.
Which means that, it doesn't matter
what value you substitute in for
x, the equation will remain true.